[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aliens sso est que lui un essai sur
canal catherine de 500 élèves tous les
mercredis et tous les mercredis on
déplace à peu près 400 à 600 élèves est
là aujourd'hui pour le reste de l'ouest
b on est arrivé sur une journée avec 6 a
à peu près 6 à elle
l'idée c'est que ceux qui veulent faire
de la compétition des rencontres le fond
il ya aussi les tous les profs de tests
qui tous les mercredis après-midi même
s'ils sont pas en compétition font des
entraînements s'occupe des élèves et il
y en a qui ne veulent pas parce toujours
partir en compétition donc ces élèves là
où ceux qui aiment bien accompagné sans
forcément pratiqué en leur trouvant rôle
en fait et on leur propose d'être jeune
officiel alors c'est varié ça peut être
reporter encore une fois ça peut être
nutrition on a des secours us aussi j'ai
oublié d'en parler important nous faut
il nous aide beaucoup sur la sécurité
[Musique]
mais cette année on a créé le rôle de
jeune officiel intégration pour
travailler avec les publics handicap un
jeu il est fort en fait c'est on a de
plus en plus de nos jours des publics
malheureusement handicapés qui viennent
dans le milieu scolaire
il faut bien trouver une façon pour les
intégrer au mieux les orcs henri lafay
de saint gilles ils sont venus c'est une
première ils sont venus à 10 il y en a
qui tiennent un stand pour expliquer ce
qu'ils sont capables de faire et il a
qui sont partis sur les activités
surtout on a des retours des élèves
c'est ce qu'on voulait qu'il soit au
contact du handicap parce que souvent
même nous des fois on voit des gens
n'osent pas trop aller où on est un
petit peu impressionné on est un petit
peu étonné et donc là les élèves l'idée
c'est ça c'est qu'ils soient au contact
et de dire bay mais si moi j'en ai dans
mon établissement collège ou lycée
je vais avoir des réactions peut-être
différente et petit à petit on se fait
pas trop d'idées mais ça va faire son
chemin et
voilà on essaie d'apporter un petit peu
la pierre à l'édifice de société qu'on
nous rabat où c'est l'équipe 2 avril un
cardiologue effectivement une envie il
ya beaucoup beaucoup de collègues
heureusement qu'ils font leur unss et
qui permet d'avoir cette dynamique il ce
que font les collègues c'est
professionnel ces professionnels et on
peut pas leur enlever ça c'est efficace
en même temps mais on espère que grâce à
une journée comme ça ça pourrait être de
bons citoyens au niveau santé au niveau
respect de l'environnement
[Musique]